6 merci beaucoup jean pierre merci
monsieur le président du conseil
national j'en profite comme j'ai le
micro simplement pour vous dire ma
fierté de porter nos couleurs dans cette
campagne
et puis vous remercier de la confiance
qui m'a été faite jean pierre tu le
rappelait tout à l'heure j'avais
simplement 12 mois de politique derrière
moi j'étais une femme de la société
civile je n'appartenais pas encore à une
formation politique et vous m'avez fait
confiance et donc aujourd'hui je tiens à
vous remercier pour cette confiance
je suis fier de porter les couleurs des
républicains d'appartenir à sept
familles politiques qui m'a fait
confiance et je suis fier avec mes deux
cent sept colistiers d'être engagés dans
cette bataille que nous allons gagner
alors le thème de cette table ronde
s'est effectivement l'emploi et vous
m'avez demandé de dax et mon
intervention tout particulièrement sur
la formation professionnelle
donc je vais être bref trois constats
d'abord vous le savez c'est la
compétence majeure de la région avec un
très gros budget la formation
professionnelle plus l'apprentissage c
31,3 milliards d'euros c'est 1 6% du pib
c'est pas rien et la région a pour sa
part 4,5 milliards d'euros de budget
alors le deuxième constat qui est bien
triste c'est que les fonds ne vont
malheureusement pas à ceux qui en ont le
plus besoin
les fonds ne vont pas au moins qualifiés
et les fonds ne vont pas aux chômeurs
moins d'un chômeur sur cinq dans ce pays
bénéficie d'une formation ce qui est
bien évidemment très faible troisième
constat l'afpa qui est l'organisme comme
vous le savez est chargé de gérer ça et
bien la cour des comptes en 2013 a
dénoncé un train de vie trop élevé 120
logements de fonction dont 60 qui sont
vacants on était au bord de la cessation
de paiement et l'afpa doit faire une
petite cure de diète avec un plan
d'économies de 107 millions jusqu'en
tout ça est assez inquiétant pour notre
pays l'afpa aider dans les 80 mille
chômeurs en 2000
en 2012 alors qu'elle en ait des 30% de
plus quelques années auparavant
donc clairement c'est un constat d'échec
voilà seulement 67 % des stagiaires afpa
trouve en france un emploi dans les six
mois et en aquitaine c'est encore pire
puisque nous ne sommes qu'à 64 %
alors ce constat d'échec et permettez
moi une seconde de parler de l'aquitaine
avec mon opposant socialiste qui fait le
pan et qui se gargarisent de son
merveilleux bilan malheureusement
l'aquitaine a le bonnet d'âne de la
croissance du chômage des jeunes en 2014
avec +5 4% et malheureusement quand on
regarde sur la formation professionnelle
l'entrée en formation en aquitaine c'est
simplement 54 7% qui vont aux chômeurs
alors que pour la moyenne en france
c'est 80 2%
donc on n'est vraiment pas bon et c'est
ce qui me fait d'ailleurs espérer que
nous allons gagner
alors face à ce constat malheureusement
assez négatif
quelques propositions la première est
notre président de région alsace a
montré la voie il faut simplement
s'attacher à une meilleure gestion
meilleure gestion des fonds publics
baisse de la dépense publique et
augmentation de l'efficacité de cette
dépense
là encore ce n'est pas une fatalité
l'exemple alsacien l'a prouvé et c'est
bien la gestion socialiste qui est au
coeur même de ces très mauvais résultats
donc emboîtons le pas de ce qu'a fait
l'alsace augmentons les performances en
termes d'apprentissage et de formation
professionnelle
deuxième sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur dans le maquis
des aides quelles qu'elles soient
c'est la simplification et là
franchement quand on regarde le système
de formation professionnelle en france
c'est complexe
c'est illisible c'est insuffisant et
c'est pas efficace 332 actions de
formation en aquitaine on n'aura pas de
mal à simplifier et surtout à augmenter
l'efficacité même de ses actions et puis
troisième et dernier point il faut qu'on
soit en anticipation et en vision
aujourd'hui la formation est
malheureusement inadapté aux besoins
même des entreprises et des
entrepreneurs et donc de ce point de vue
là on doit en répondre à la tente des
entreprises vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
50% des intentions d'embauché
malheureusement on crée une énorme
difficulté de recrutement notamment en
ce qui nous concerne en aquitaine
limousin poitou charentes dans les
métiers de services dans les métiers du
tourisme dans les métiers de
l'innovation
de ce point de vue là nous sommes en
retard et nous avons à mais mieux
adapter notre système de formation aux
débouchés
et puis là encore anticipation et
visions ce qui nous importe c'est de
préparer aux métiers de demain les
métiers de demain c'est des métiers de
l'innovation c'est des métiers de
l'informatique c'est les métiers du
numérique et en cela nous sommes très en
retard très à la traîne et c'est ça que
nous voulons a pas
arte dans la réforme du système de
formation professionnelle de nos régions
alors je pense à monsieur merci je pense
à mon opposant socialiste qui souvent se
gargarise de ces bons résultats et vous
savez combien nous sommes attachés en
aquitaine à l'aéronautique et ça me fait
penser à la visière des casques des
rafales à la réalité augmentée et bien
malheureusement la gestion socialiste
c'est ça c'est de la réalité augmentée
en permanence mais quand on regarde de
très près et bien finalement le bilan
n'est pas brillant y compris pour le
président de la rfef président sortant
du conseil régional aquitaine limousin
poitou charentes
merci encore de votre confiance